ça fait un petit moment qu'on n'a pas
fait un trait dehors et je vais vous
dire pourquoi j'ai aucune excuse ne
sommes que ça aujourd'hui trois
histoires d'horreur comme d'habitude on
commence avec une assez longue puis une
moyenne courte puis re une longue
nous allons frissonner tous ensemble moi
je vous avons en ce moment je suis très
d'humeur à rester chez moi du coup là je
raconte des histoires qui se passent un
peu dehors comme ça je deviens pas
parano chez moi bien quand même une qui
se passe chez quelqu'un et quelqu'un
peut pas donc on commence avec
l'histoire d'alexandre élection de
correa raconte son histoire c'est lui
arrivait que quelques heures plus tôt
c'est un habitué du sabri dit let's not
me it's already sur lequel je pioche ses
histoires il lui est arrivé un truc
vraiment flippant et du courant tron il
s'est dit [ __ ] je vais pouvoir prendre
parti à se sevrer dit enfin
malheureusement aujourd'hui alexandre a
fini le travail plus tôt et du coup il a
donc décidé d'aller faire un petit
footing il est partie courir vers 16h30
et ses itinéraires de footing habituel
passe à travers de nombreuses routes
vu l'heure et tous les gens qui rentrent
du travail et s'est dit que ce serait
pas très pratique donc il a décidé de
prendre un autre itinéraire
cet autre itinéraire le fait passer à
travers des bois tout ce qui est plus
classique pour faire un footing
finalement est le chemin le fait arriver
proche des restes d'une usine et cette
usine là son escalier et un taxe un
escalier de secours en métal et sur
l'une des marches en métal se trouve un
mec assis à la vue d'alex ce mec
aussitôt se lève et lui crie quelque
chose il comprend qu'il est peut-être
dans une entourloupe mais ça n'inquiète
pas plus que ça puisque à une clôture
entre lui et ce mec et que donc dans le
pire des cas bas il va reprendre le
footing est taillé son meilleur sprinter
barrière lui arriver alex continue son
footing et arrive au niveau de ce mec
qui lui dit attendez s'il vous plaît
aidez-moi à trouver mon téléphone
téléphone qu'il aurait apparemment
laissé tomber quelque part à proximité
et demande alors à alex d'appeler son
numéro pour que la sonnerie du téléphone
les aide à localiser
alex à ce moment là il a un peu pris au
piège parce qu'ils en plein footing et
vous savez il à la sacoche en plastique
sur le bras dans laquelle se trouve son
téléphone il peut pas prétexter ne pas
avoir de téléphone puisqu'il est
accrochée à son bras alex commence à
taper le numéro sur son téléphone et il
a même pas le temps de finir le numéro
que la personne en face de lui lui dit
ça y est je l'entends allez viens
m'aider à chercher alex reste sans voix
il comprend pas et se dit mais j'ai pas
fini de taper le numéro il peut pas
l'entendre son téléphone puisqu'ils
sommes pas il s'apprête à lui dire
lorsque soudainement il aperçoit un
deuxième à quelques mètres à droite
d'alex derrière une section de mur ce
deuxième homme au regard d'alex et lui
dit les gars le téléphone est à côté de
moi je l'entends il est très près de moi
et il fait alors signé alex de passer
dans un trou de la clôture pour venir
les aider c'est à dire que depuis le
début alex qui se sentait pas en
sécurité grâce
c'est une [ __ ] de clôture de l'été en
fête absolument pas les deux gars vont
alors demandé à l'ex plusieurs fois de
les rejoindre de l'autre côté de les
aider en insistant bien sur le fait
qu'ils entendent le téléphone sonner et
qu'il est tout près alex et dans
l'hésitation et sait pas quoi faire et
il entend le deuxième type dire à son
ami il va pas tomber non pas nous et
cette phrase il l'a dit à voix basses
pensions qu'alex ne l'entendrait pas
sauf qu'ils sont au milieu d'une forêt
et qui a aucun bruit et c'est là que le
premier gars commencent à s'énerver il
se met à frapper contre un arbre et dit
alex de se bouger le cul parce qu'il a
vraiment besoin de ce téléphone et que
toute sa vie se trouve dans ce téléphone
est face à la colère de ce premier homme
alex constate autre chose c'est que le
deuxième homme a disparu
il ne sait pas où il est alex balaye
tout ce qu'il a devant lui des yeux dans
le but de retrouver le deuxième individu
qui est potentiellement une menace aussi
pour alex et ils voient que le deuxième
homme est en fait en train de passer
dans le trou de la clôture
la situation est en train de dégénérer
alex le comprends parfaitement et il
décide de taper sur bay street après 20
secondes de sprint alex décident de
regarder par dessus son épaule pour voir
s'il est suivi ou pas et bonne nouvelle
il ne poursuivent pas ils sont tous les
deux debout de l'autre côté de la
clôture au milieu du chemin
immobile à regarder alex partir en
courant alex a continué de sprinter
jusqu'à chez lui et il a bel et bien
compris que s'ils avaient rejoint les
deux hommes de l'autre côté de la
clôture pour les aider mais il aurait
été sacrément dans la merde voilà et
c'est la fin de l'histoire d'alex celle
là elle est pour tous ceux qui font du
jogging là comme des beaux gosses dans
la forêt attention à vous c'est horrible
parce que c'est vraiment ce truc
d'embuscades où il ya des gens qui font
semblant d'être dans le besoin et qui te
pressurise genre vite vite agi vite
viens vite de notre côté et elle nous
est souvent sur le moment tu es un peu
choqués que des gars soit dans le besoin
et tu peux facilement te rapprocher
d'eux et pc tu as gardé te retrouver mal
donc voilà alex tu as eu un très bon
faire ce jour là bravo à toi
il est temps de passer à l'histoire de
carl et cette histoire elle se passe
dans son appartement à l'époque car le
vit seule dans un petit appartement et
tout se passe pour le mieux jusqu'à ce
qu'ils notifient des trucs qui
disparaissent ou qui changent de place
il ouvre le placard de sa cuisine et les
gâteaux ne sont pas au même endroit que
la veille ils rentrent du travail en fin
de journée il se rend dans son salon et
les coussins sont désordonnées vous
savez c'est le genre de truc vous vous
et moi ça nous arrivait et en fait c'est
juste nous qui avons bougé de place les
trucs et on s'en souvient pas mais car
lui c'est lui met la puce à l'oreille et
il se met à se méfier de son propre
appartement pour lui il est clair que
quelque chose ne tourner pas rond
tout cela nous amène à cette fameuse
nuit où karl se réveille à une heure du
matin
en sueur il est convaincu qu'il sort
d'un cauchemar même s'ils s'en souvient
pas et décide d'aller prendre une douche
parce que là il a vraiment reçu ils
seront alors dans sa salle de bain et il
pose son téléphone sur le lavabo et semé
une petite musique cool pour profiter de
ce moment sous la douche et laisser cet
affreux cauchemar loin derrière lui
après plusieurs minutes passées sous la
douche
karl entend la porte de la salle de
bains bouger comme il vit seul il la
ferme jamais et encore moins à clé et
surtout il a pas d'animaux donc ça ne
peut pas être son chat ou son chien qui
a rentré dans la salle de bains entre
carl et l'entrée de la salle de bain se
trouve à rideaux de douche et là car il
va faire un truc très malin pour être
sûr de pas se faire des idées il va
regarder tout en étant hors du champ de
vision de cette possible personne qui
vient d'entrer dans sa salle de bain le
reflet de son téléphone qui
souvenez-vous se trouvent sur son lavabo
et dans le reflet de son téléphone et
voit bel et bien quelqu'un qui ait deux
bouts de l'autre côté de son rideau
touche hélas karl effet un truc de beau
gosse il garde son sang froid il a bel
et bien la preuve que quelqu'un est là
dans sa salle de bain mais il va faire
comme si de rien n'était il va pas crier
il va pas s'agiter
il va continuer sa douche comme s'ils
n'avaient rien vu mais en vrai il
prépare un plan d'attaqué
il saisit son pommeau de douche et aimer
l'eau chaude à fond et carl il ya un
truc relou dans son appart mais qui dans
cette situation se trouve être une
chance c'est que sont nos chaudes
montrent très très haute température
quelques secondes plus tard il ya
beaucoup de vapeur dans la douche et
surtout car à mal au pied puisqu'il se
prend un peu d'eau sur les pieds et
qu'elle est vraiment brûlante
il prend alors son courage à deux mains
et décide d'ouvrir le rideau de douche
et d'orienter le pommeau vers la
personne qui se trouvait de l'autre côté
cette personne qui vient de se faire
début
t hurle de douleur et carl décide de la
frapper au visage avec la pomme de
douche et de courir hors de sa salle de
bain avant de fermer à clé la porte de
la salle de bain de l'extérieur il vient
de réussir à en fermer
l'intrus dans sa propre salle de bain il
appelle alors la police et le temps
qu'elles se rendent sur les lieux et
décide d'aller dans sa cuisine pour
s'armer d'un couteau au cas où la porte
sédré sous les coups de l'intrus et
qu'ils auraient à se défendre et
mauvaise surprise en arrivant dans sa
cuisine son gros couteau de cuisine
n'est plus à son emplacement et carl
comprend immédiatement qu'il est très
probablement en ce moment même dans la
salle de bains entre les mains de
l'intrus la police arrive alors sur les
lieux et arrête cette femme qui était
toujours enfermé dans la salle de bain
et il se trouve que c'était l'ancien
locataire de l'appartement
en fait elle s'était fait virer de
l'appartement après ne pas avoir payé le
loyer pendant plusieurs mois sauf
qu'elle avait fait un double des clés et
qu'elle avait donc toujours depuis
plusieurs mois accès à l'appartement de
carlo et elle s'y rendait régulièrement
sur les heures de travail de karl pour
manger se doucher et c est ce qu a fait
vraiment bas des 15 c'est que la police
a bel et bien retrouvé son gros couteau
de cuisine dans la salle de bain et que
les choses auraient donc pu vraiment mal
tourner s'ils n'avaient pas de l'eau qui
montait à une très haute température et
un verrou qui peut se fermer de
l'extérieur la salle de bain
bref on va tous installés des serrure à
clé suite à cette histoire et je dois
vous dire un truc moi par exemple n'y a
aucun verrou chez moi à part aux
toilettes et ça se faire un peu de
l'intérieur donc s'il m'arrive ça je
suis complètement hub le couteau il
transperce mon corps tôt ou tard c'est
sûr j'adore cette histoire parce que bon
déjà elle finit bien il n'est rien
arrivé à karl et surtout il lui arrivait
ce qui se passe dans plein de films
d'horreur quelqu'un de mal intentionné
rentrer dans la salle de bains est comme
l'eau coule le personnage principal
n'entend pas l'intrus est entré dans la
salle de bains fin bref il a vraiment
vécu un truc de films d'horreur tout ça
fout
mais ce drame il est temps de passer à
la dernière histoire ssl d'alison
allison est de retour dans la maison
familiale pour la première fois depuis
un an puisqu'elle vient de finir sa
première année d'université
elle y retourne pour y passer les
grandes vacances et elle explique que
cette maison familiale elle n'est pas
située en ville elle est située bien
plus loin et c'est vraiment le cliché de
la maison en pleine forêt genre cette
maison est entourée de forêts denses
près de la maison familiale il ya un
petit sentier herbeux du long duquel
découle un ruisseau et si on suit ce
ruisseau on tombe sur la grande rivière
-selon marche de plusieurs heures mais
qu'elle faisait souvent quand il était
enfant
allison précise que dans cette forêt
c'est très simple de se perdre elle est
très dense et surtout le terrain n'est
pas du tout droit il ya beaucoup de
montées et de descentes
bref cet été-là allison a décidé de
refaire la sortie qu'elle a fait tant de
fois quand elle était plus jeune à deux
reprises la première fois elle est
partie le matin elle a atteint le
ruisseau au bout d'environ une heure
arrivé au ruisseau elle décide de
tromper ses mains dans l'eau et c'est là
qu'au loin elle entend une cloche il
faut savoir que lors de cette sortie
typique qu'elle a fait des centaines de
fois au cours de sa vie à l'essonne n'a
jamais croisé n'ai vu personne en
marchant elle réfléchit et elles sont
content que ça peut pas être une cloche
accroché un animal puisque le bruit de
la cloche est beaucoup trop fort elle
continue tout de même à marcher en
direction du bruit de la cloche mais
après cinq minutes il n'y a plus aucun
bruit de cloche
elle comprend que la théorie la plus
probable c'est que ce soit un humain qui
façonnaient cette cloche mais elle a pas
trop envie d'y penser elle refuse d'y
croire
après plusieurs dizaines de minutes de
marche elle tombe sur un blaireau
monstres et c'était assez récent puisque
le corps était assez frais y avait pas
d'odeur nauséabonde
allison continue son chemin elle atteint
sa destination chez elle il n'y a rien
d'autre d'étrange à noter une semaine
plus tard c'est le moment où allison
fait cette deuxième sortie et
malheureusement ça va aussi être sa
dernière
cette fois elle parle pas le matin elle
part à 18 heures elle atteint le
ruisseau et cette fois ci elle va pas
continuer son chemin jusqu'à atteindre
la rivière comme à chaque fois elle va
tout de suite faire demi tour parce
qu'il pleut à torrent et en plus il est
tard le soleil se couche à 21h elle n'a
pas envie de rentrer de nuit donc à les
courses sa sortie allison qui marchent à
toute vitesse atteint la partie la plus
claire et la plus ouverte de la forêt et
elle tombe nez à nez sur quelque chose
accroché à une branche quelque chose
dont se dégage une odeur terrible et ce
quelque chose c'est le corps en
décomposition du blaireau elle comprend
donc que quelqu'un connaît le chemin
qu'elle emprunte et qu'il a mis ce corps
de blaireaux à cet endroit là dans le
but qu'elles tombent dessus
elle se met alors à regarder autour
d'elle
et à devenir un peu parano elle se
demande si les branches qui craquent
autour d'elle ne sont pas des animaux
mais une personne qui la suite si
quelqu'un est là depuis le début au loin
et la traque et elle décide alors de
courir
elle court et s'éloigne du ruisseau
lorsque d'un coup elle entend la cloche
pendant qu'elle court elle appelle son
père elle lui dit qu'elle est persuadée
que quelqu'un se trouve dans la forêt
avec elle et qu'elle un très mauvais
pressentiment
il fait nuit il pleut à torrent le bruit
des gouttes d'eau qui frappe sur les
feuilles et les arbres alentour
n'empêche de distinguer les sons mais
elle en est convaincu quelqu'un est très
proche d'elle
allison est à bout de souffle ça fait
plusieurs minutes quel prix elle décide
alors de se remettre à marcher vite et
c'est là qu'elle va pour la première
fois distingué débrouille et ses bruits
ses des bruits de pas ces bruits pas
viennent d'un peu plus bas dans la forêt
et rapidement après elle entend de
nouveau un son de cloche qui vient du
même endroit que s'ébruite pas allison
arrête de marché elle est pétrifié elle
décide de regarder par dessus son épaule
et elle va enfin voir ce qui se trouve
dans cette forêt avec elle elle
distingue au bout du chemin
un homme légèrement accroupi qui marche
vers l tout en 2d devant lui cette
fameuse cloche
allison comprend que depuis le début
elle n'est pas en train de se faire des
idées elle n'est pas la bienvenue sur ce
chemin et quelqu'un veut lui faire
comprendre
elle se remet alors à sprinter de toutes
ses forces tout en hurlant qu'elle est
au téléphone avec la police et qu'ils
sont en route
allison explique qu'à ce moment là elle
a le sentiment que quelque chose de
terrible va lui arriver que l'homme
court plus vite qu'elle qu'ils se
rapprochent d'elle et qu'elle n'aura pas
eu le temps de retrouver son père avant
qu'il la tête et après plusieurs longues
minutes de sprint elle entend au loin la
voix de son père qui hurle son prénom
allison saute dans les bras de son père
et ils se ruent tous deux dans la
voiture que son père avait garée un peu
plus loin à l'entrée d'un chemin qui
vous pouvez pas emprunter avec la
voiture
une fois dans la voiture le perdre à
l'histoire de la conduite directement au
commissariat
sur la route son père est en larmes et
expliqué alyson qu'il entendait le bruit
de la cloche et qu'il était persuadé
qu'il n'allait plus jamais revoir sa
fille arriver au commissariat la police
évidemment à donner les premiers soins à
allison et ensuite ils sont rendus sur
les lieux pour essayer de trouver cet
homme qui faisait sonner cette cloche
malheureusement ils ont pas trouvé tout
ce qu'ils ont trouvé c'était un t-shirt
plié sous un rocher
ils ont alors conclu que cet homme était
probablement un sans abri qui vivaient
dans la forêt et qu'il n'avait
absolument pas apprécié le fait qu
allison se balade aux alentours de son
endroit et ont rien pu faire pour
allison et sa famille à part leur dire
d'être très vigilants et de ne plus
cet endroit allison essayer de
rationaliser tous ces événements et
malheureusement elle est convaincue que
ce gars allaient lui faire du mal
puisque c'est pas normal la manière dont
il marche et après elle c'est pas normal
la manière dont faisait sonner la cloche
c'est comme s'il était satisfait de la
traquer et qui se nourrissait de sapeurs
en fait elle elle est donc jamais
retourné se balader dans la forêt est
aujourd'hui dès qu'elle entend un son de
cloche elle est complètement paniquée
c'est devenu un vrai cauchemar pour elle
bref elle n'a jamais su qui était cette
personne est ce qu'elle voulait et elle
le sera jamais nous arrivons à la fin de
ces trois histoires
j'ai l'impression qu'on va plutôt faire
de balades en forêt avant un moment mais
je vous le dis il a formé sa macho febba
d&g des bonnes raisons visibilité
réduite terrain que je ne maîtrise pas
d'ebouri dans tous les sens à ne plus
savoir d'où ils viennent à moi la forêt
c'est non mais même en plein jour
moi la forêt c'est nous mêmes car bien
ce truc là de clé à chaque fois que j'ai
déménagé dans ma vie je voulais
absolument changer la serrure et les
clés parce que j'avais peur que ce qui
est arrivé à karl m'arrive
d'accord ça m'est jamais arrivé
heureusement mais sachez que moi quand
je suis chez moi je laisse toujours la
clé sur la porte pour que même si
quelqu'un qui a un double des clés
veille rentrée eh ben il ne puisse pas à
moi je les colle pas merci à vous
d'avoir regardé ça dérange fer qui vous
a plu à bientôt pour d'autres histoires
le prochain sera dans très peu de temps
vu que c'est bientôt halloween on va
faire un truc spécial à l'occasion
portez vous bien plein de bonnes choses
des gros bisous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]